hi in this video we're going to talk
about the fasted State our body gets
food input in terms of carbohydrate
protein and fats we have all these three
in our diet in contrast to carbohydrate
and proteins the calorific value of fat
is more but even if our body has options
between all of these well body would
preferably use carbohydrate as a source
to generate energy but in case of
fasting we don't have any calories
cooking input so all of these sources
are not available during fasting and we
are not eating anything externally so
nutrients are limiting right let's look
at what happens or what changes happens
during the fasted State so let's look at
first what happens to the liver then we
move on to brain muscles and adipose
tissue before understanding what happens
during the fasted State we need to
understand what are the normal pathways
happening in the liver hepatocytes
during a fade state when glucose is
abundant we imagine glucose is abundant
so glucose would be channeled into
glycolytic pathway and it would form
pyruvate along with it it would produce
ATP pyruvate would be channeled into
Krebs cycle and oxidative
phosphorylation would take place to
generate more ATP in short when there is
plenty of glucose plenty of ATP would be
generated as well now from glucose there
would be additional synthesis of
glycogen which would work like a reserve
for the future glucose could also be
channeled into pentose phosphate pathway
from glucose 6-phosphate which is a
glycolytic intermediate it can divert it
into pentose phosphate pathway only when
glucose is available in plenty amount
pentose phosphate pathway generates
NADPH the reducing equivalent which is
important for other kind of biosynthetic
pathways such as fatty acid biosynthesis
pathway
all of these metabolic pathways would
only happen when glucose is there but in
fasted State glucose is low as you can
understand all of these pathway that we
have discussed so far would kind of
stopped right it would be stopped but
body cannot afford that because liver
even in the fasted State requires energy
so how it would happen now liver need to
have alternative sources and the
alternative sources are like glycogen
glycogen was already stored in the liver
during fed state and that glycogen is
now going to be broken down and it would
create glucose it is very much similar
that you have more money you are fixing
that money in your bank account and
later you can break that fixed deposit
and use that money right exactly
depending upon the demand the body is
breaking glycogen and making glucose now
TCA cycle and pyruvate can also give
rise to new glucose Enoch pathway and
form glucose so initially just after
starving what you would try to fight
back and generate glucose by channeling
TCA cycle intermediates to new yoga
genic pathway and breaking down glycogen
all these things ensures that glucose is
secreted from the liver into the
bloodstream and can reach the brain
because brain need blue cows more than
anything else because for brain glucose
is a key source of functioning and in
started our body cannot stop functioning
now liver has alternative sources such
such as fatty acid which comes from the
adipose tissue this fatty acid would be
oxidized to acetyl cool as I tell you I
can be channeled into site TCA cycle but
for long term fasting as a telco I would
generate ketone bodies and the ketone
bodies would also be secreted into the
bloodstream
now let's look at the hormonal situation
during fasting now in red state we know
insulin level is high and pancreatic
beta cell secretes insulin but in the
Fed in the fasted state when the glucose
level is low while fasting
no it cannot enter the pancreatic
beta-cell as a result the pancreatic
beta-cell is in a hyper polarized state
in the hyperpolarized state the
pancreatic beta-cell can not secrete
insulin rather than glucagon is secreted
which increase the blood glucose level
this situation is very much similar when
you don't have money in your hand to pay
bills in that situation you take two
fold
states one if you break your savings to
pay your bills and at that situation you
stop saving more right exactly same
thing our body is performing under a
fasted state but it stops all sort of
anabolic processes rather it focuses
more on catabolic processes to generate
the energy okay let's look at how little
body generation is taking place under a
fasted state in this situation the liver
is producing ketone bodies which would
be utilized by the brain and many other
extrahepatic tissues such as cardiac
muscle and etcetera so brain cannot stop
working so brain need alternative fuel
and the reserve will would be the ketone
bodies now in the star state the source
of ketone body biogenesis comes from the
adipose tissue that opposed tissue
breaks down try design to give rise to
fatty acid and the fatty acid is
oxidized which give rise to acetyl
Kuwait that acetyl co a can be used to
generate ketone bodies once ketone
bodies generated in the liver it could
be used in heart brain and kidneys
now the ketone bodies can cross the
blood-brain barrier as a result it can
easily enter the brain remember fatty
acid cannot cross blood-brain barrier
otherwise when could have you to utilize
fatty acid but Rin has no option because
fatty acid can not reach the brain
because it is prevented by the
blood-brain barrier okay after that let
us understand the molecular mechanism by
which body responds to a starved state
in the stand state
ATP level would be super low whereas EMP
level would be high
it'd be level is low because it'll be is
generated less amount and the glucose is
yes this ATP by my ratio change would be
detected by a sensor which is known as
ampk or impede dependent kinase which is
also known as master regulator of
catabolism so AMPK would ensure
catabolic processes are enhanced and
AMPK also induce that tuber sclerosis
complex which is an inhibitor of mTOR
pathway now inter pathway is anabolic
pathway so mTOR pathway is a master
regulator for all the anabolic pathway
other than that this NPK activates PG C
1 alpha PCC 1 alpha also activates PPAR
alpha all of these helps in
transcription of ketogenesis related
genes and enzymes that ensures that in
fasted state ketogenesis is favored and
all the anabolic processes are stopped
ok let's look at the brain to bring
under normal circumstances imagine this
is a fed state in this circumstances it
can use the glucose and from glucose
under glycolysis it would form pyruvic
acid then the Krebs cycle can go on and
brain can get its energy but brain
doesn't care where does the acetyl co a
comes from acetyl co a is required for
this Krebs cycle to go on now brain can
either take it from glucose or brain can
take it in form of the ketone bodies the
ketone bodies that comes into the brain
would be metabolized the major ketone
body that is in the brain during fasted
state is beta hydroxy butyrate which in
subsequent steps by the enzyme beta
hydroxy butyrate dehydrogenase gets
converted to acetyl acetate now
acetoacetate get converted to beta key
to si Co a transference by so it is
getting converted to acetyl acetate and
Kawai by beta t 2 aerosol transferase
this particular enzyme which is marked
in red this transfer is in line is
exclusive to brain and gives brain the
ability to utilize ketone
liver can only generate ketone body it
cannot you
but as a extra hepatic tissue brain can
utilize the ketone bodies ultimately it
would give rise to acetyl co a which can
be utilized and the krebs cycle or the
TCA cycle can run again and this is how
under feds under fasted State brain use
ketone bodies as a alternative source of
will and bring can now recharge itself
again not only brain under fasted State
heart muscle cannot stop pumping
similarly the kidney cannot stop
filtering the blood and reduces cannot
stop producing urine so all these are
necessary physiological processes that
need to go on even in the fasted State
kidney and heart both has the Beto T 2's
I'll Kuwait transferase enzyme which is
key enzyme for breakdown of the ketone
bodies both kidney and heart can break
down ketone bodies and ultimately both
the cases the acetyl co a which is
generated can be channeled into TCA
cycle and they can generate their own
energies now animals tissues has
different kind of changes happening
under the fasted State adipose tissue is
a rich reserve for cholesterol for
triglyceride and etc the triglyceride
would be broken and in the adipose
tissue the fatty acid which is the by
product of triglyceride breakdown would
be further broken down into acetyl co a
by PT oxidation in the mitochondria of
these adipose tissue this acetyl co a
can either run into the TCA cycle give
the adipose tissue energy but under
prolong circumstances it would be
secreted this acetyl co a would be
secreted or the fatty acid could also be
secreted and that would reach the liver
and river liver can use that acetyl co a
for a duration or majorly would produce
ketone bodies under prolonged stage of
starvation and the starve and during
starvation ketone body is the main
source of energy not only that there are
many other hormones which are secreted
during the fasted state for example the
adrenal cortex secretes bucco corticoids
such as cortisol
middle a secret safe in a screen and the
pancreas secrets
Luca got by the alpha cells of the
pancreas now all of these hormones which
are secreted in the fasted state ensures
protein catabolism increase and there is
a decrease in protein anabolism if the
protein catabolism is increased then the
by-product could be used but those amino
acid could be used to even produce
glucose by new glucose genic pathway in
this way hormonal regulation all these
organs they are communicating with each
other under fasted State to make our
physiology get going our brain cannot
stop our liver cannot stop our heart
cannot stop even under fasted State the
alternative pathways are activated and
it ensures our body can run its
necessary physiological processes so I
hope this video was helpful if you liked
this video give it a big thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe thank
you